imagine a brand-new piece of technology
that puts a computer in your lap well
it's here and it's called a laptop it
has all the modern parts and it frees
you from your desk it has a great screen
and keyboard but the powerful computing
on the go yes it's 2015 and this year's
cutting edge piece of technology it's
called a laptop this 30 year old form
factor is still the future even
Microsoft has finally decided to make
one but it's not so simple you see the
surface book is also a tablet and the
new surface pro 4 tablet is also billed
as a laptop I know it makes your brain
hurt but pay attention because these
really do give us a glimpse at the
future where our devices collide look
you will either love or hate the surface
books design especially the bendy straw
like hinge me I love it and no random
things don't get stuck in the gap my
main complaints the laptop is chunky and
the lid is just too hard to get open
once you get it open though you're in
laptop heaven the pixel pack screen is
beautiful the keyboard is very
comfortable and most of the time the
glass trackpad works great periodically
though the cursor does get stuck
everything was going amazing I was
almost ready to call the surface book
the perfect Windows laptop until one
night um did Windows just completely
stopped working do I really need to
reinstall the whole thing one surface
book and one surface pro 4 I tested just
refused to boot up again and others had
persistent software issues Microsoft
says that this has been addressed at the
factory and customers won't experience
it if Microsoft fixes those issues the
book could be the near perfect Windows
laptop as a tablet though it still has
some other problems there's some
noticeable wobble on the screen because
when you press this key the whole thing
comes off holding a 1.6 pound tablet
like this is kind of awkward but holding
it like this
it's pretty comfortable the included pen
is smoother and quieter to write with
than the older surface pens though a
slight delay keeps it from matching the
experience of writing on paper then
again you can't do this with paper
speaking of faces you can now use yours
to log into the computer take that long
passwords inside the tablet are the guts
of a laptop my $1,500 base unit has
everything but a big battery and that's
a big problem in tablet mode I got an
embarrassing 2.5 hours on my test
luckily the keyboard base has an
extended battery that got me an
impressive 10 hours the surface pro 4
tablet lasted 5.5 hours
worse the pro doesn't have a battery in
its keyboard dock
although the keys and trackpad are
improved still if I was laptop shopping
in the thousand dollar range
I picked the Dell XPS 13 over the pro 4
but if money is no object and Microsoft
fixes those issues I experienced I'd say
the surface book is the best Windows
laptop I've ever used no it's not the
best tablet at least not yet but at some
point soon we won't think of our tablets
as anything but the top halves of our
laptop because it sits in your lap
you